fashion babies cooking our finger
boogers stuck in the 50s women have been
fighting for decades to be taken
seriously in the world of work but when
I look at all this young female boogers
all I have to say is this is not a way
to go they're all just slogging about
fashion babies cooking posting lots of
glossy cute photos where are the women
blogging about science high-tech
economics politics or even car repair
they just reinforce all these
stereotypes about women that all we care
about is lifestyle and cooking so why do
they do it Jessica vices Germany's most
successful female blogger I wanted to
answer these burning questions
[Music]
Jessica our female bloggers stuck in the
50s 9s thank me you know I don't think
so it's taken a decade just to develop a
job description when I started blogging
it wasn't a profession today I'm able to
earn a living with it I'm fairly well
known and I can pay my entire team with
it we're making progress all the time
anchored against its side were fun you
write about fashion why do you do it and
a Cellini really sagging that's it
first of all I'm passionate about
fashion and I have been since I was a
girl you have to listen to your gut
feeling I'm someone who tends to think
things through and I've developed my
product in a gradual and deliberate way
I wanted to establish a brand
I turned down plenty of offers to
collaborate which could have been quite
lucrative
but they didn't fit my brand Selenia
forget about it and I began to market
your posture come on ladies life is much
more than clothing cooking and kids we
left the kitchen decades ago and that
also holds in a digital world
[Music]